the united nations is calling this a
voyage of hope a ship laden with 26 000
metric tons of corn led through mined
waters by a ukrainian tugboat
the first to leave these ports since the
russian invasion this ship the merchant
vessel razone
is loaded with two commodities in short
supply corn
and hope
hope for millions of people around the
world will depend on the smooth running
of ukraine sports to feed their families
the vessel left this morning after a
deal between russia and ukraine was
brokered by the un and turkey last week
if the voyage goes as planned through
the kremlin's naval blockade of the
black sea it will hopefully be the first
of many
ukraine is known as the breadbasket of
europe it's a leading producer of
sunflowers barley corn and wheat
and since the war began the threat of
famine has loomed in many places around
the world
this is a country ukraine that fed 400
million people last year with the food
that it exported but this is one of the
critical countries in the world that we
need to guarantee continues to export
food
to vulnerable countries to food insecure
countries and to help feed people all
over the world
but the deal is unlikely to be plain
sailing the tempo of this war shows no
sign of slowing the grain deal is
extremely precarious and it is easy to
understand why
as the ship was being prepared for
departure russia was attacking targets
across the country
this was a hospital a couple of hours
down the road from the port of odessa it
was struck by a massive missile there is
no trust between russia and ukraine and
the fear is the deal could break down
very quickly
the director of this laboratory says
attacks like this don't inspire
confidence
but for the moment as the ship makes its
way into turkish waters for inspection
and then its final destination of
lebanon there is some optimism
to have got this far is a significant
achievement the hope is the deal will
hold to ease a food crisis that's
already being felt in some of the
poorest parts of the world
alex rossi sky news
odessa